leadership mayor thank you for the warm
welcome
so here's the thing who doesn't love a
yellow school bus right can you raise
your hand if you love a yellow school
bus right just there's something about
the and and most of us many of us went
to school on the yellow school bus right
and it's part of it's part of our our
experience growing up it's part of you
know a Nostalgia and a member
foreign
Rubin uh that was Kamala Harris and
there's something wrong with that woman
it is October 27 2022 we're live
streaming on Rumble YouTube and Blaze TV
as always uh subscribe tap that
notification Bell if you have not we
have a big dense jam-packed program for
you today but we did have to add
something in this morning because I woke
up this morning and this device which we
all have and many of us leave on our
nightstand at night and it's probably
emitting all kinds of radio waves and
God knows what
electromagnetic static and who knows
frying all of our brains most of us keep
it on our nightstand I really try not to
I try not to every now and again I do I
woke up this morning my phone was like
burning hot it was melting I had a
gajillion notifications what's happening
what's happening
turns out that this Donald Trump guy you
remember Donald Trump former president
of the United States uh he on I was
going to say he tweeted out he did not
tweet it out on Truth social uh which is
his social network which actually is has
a pretty decent amount of traction and I
am posting on there as well uh last
night Donald Trump clipped a portion of
my interview with Megan Kelly from about
10 days ago where I was asking Megan
what she thought about the DeSantis vs
Trump situation uh and Trump got a clip
of it put it out on truth and uh well
basically all hell's been breaking loose
so here is the the portion it's about a
minute long that Trump sent out if they
got on the stage you don't think that
the scientist is Crafty enough or who
stands enough really interesting I don't
even think that a little
um I think Trump sucks up all the energy
in every room no matter what and even
someone is skilled as a politician and
smart policy wise as DeSantis can't
overcome that you can't you really think
the hardcore Maga is gonna abandon Trump
or DeSantis they're not they they like
DeSantis but they don't think it's his
turn they think Trump is screwed out of
his last election that he was screwed
out of his first term by all the
craziness of the Russia gate and so on
and they think he's he is entitled he
deserves another shot at it like the
hardcore Trump faithful he's unshakable
they like DeSantis but they would never
cross Trump for him and they think that
DeSantis owes his political career to
Trump like if forced to choose they will
choose Trump so DeSantis can't take him
down it's like the line in war games the
only winning move is not to play
DeSantis has got to either be crowned by
Trump
um or he shouldn't run he won't win over
Trump fight I'll stand by that you can
play it against me if I'm wrong but I
won't be
okay pretty interesting stuff and
obviously Megan Kelly is opinionated you
know Trump has actually gone after Megan
Kelly let's not forget one of those
first debates uh when he went directly
after her uh by the way before I even
get into this anymore I just want to
send I I've already uh texted her but I
want to send a little love directly to
you Megan Kelly because Megan lost her
sister who's only 58 years old she lost
her a couple days ago so just sending
some extra love to you Megan
um what's interesting about this
obviously is that Trump has not
announced that he is running for
president DeSantis certainly has not
announced that he is running for
president but but the tension exists and
as I've been saying for quite some time
the media really really wants there to
be a rift here because they know how bad
the Democrats are looking you know how
bad the Democrats are looking the polls
are showing how bad the Democrats are
looking they have a guy who in essence
you know has some form of dementia
leading the party and everyone else are
just sort of woke Progressive nut bags
and and the party has to just continue
down that path until it implodes and
then we'll see as I always say maybe a
phoenix can Rise From the Ashes of the
democratic party but I wouldn't hold my
breath so in in essence what the media
really needs is Trump to destroy
DeSantis or DeSantis to destroy Trump
now I actually agree with some of what
Megan is saying there for sure uh that
the base the hardcore Maga bass and I
say this as a guy that voted for Trump
and if this has just doesn't run I will
support Trump for sure like it's not
even a question and I'm absolutely maybe
it won't be either one of them but I'm
voting for a republican no matter what I
can't imagine the Democrats magically uh
putting someone saying up but
the hardcore Trump base the people that
are out there at the rallies and with
the flags and all of those things I
sense that if both of the guys were
running Trump into sand it's like
they're going to go Trump it's just how
it is now I don't know that that that's
how you win you'd get a sort of winning
Coalition by just going to the base
however in a primary you kind of do have
to get the base so what what Megan
really is talking about there is a
tactical thing like it's a tactical how
do you get through the primaries to
become president she isn't saying who
she thinks at least In that clip wasn't
saying who she thinks would actually
make a better president right who would
actually be a more effective leader who
could get more done etc etc she's
talking about a tactical Point anyway we
shall see how this all plays out and
again to me
it's like this is sort of win-win either
way let's say Trump announces he's
running well okay you know what you're
getting with Trump right and then
DeSantis is like okay I'm just not going
to run well DeSantis is about to crush
it in his re-election next week in
essence and it's like all right so then
DeSantis will stay here in Florida and
Florida will do great and hopefully
Trump will win and it's it's all good so
I think a lot of you know the me I could
see the media is going all over this
thing and it's like they want these guys
to destroy each other I don't think it's
necessarily going to happen I want to
show you a uh a headline and a bit of an
article uh from Politico this is from
yesterday uh Trump to hold rally in
Florida with Rubio but not DeSantis it's
written by two guys uh Matt Dixon and
Gary fine out I didn't know who they
were until this morning I did a little
check in on Twitter because I read the
article and as I've been saying to you
guys for quite some time this is what
the media wants they want there to be a
collision between these two because that
is the the thing that could destroy the
Republicans obviously you split the
party in two congratulations we get more
Democrat rule so I've read the article I
don't like reading things from Politico
because it's it's trash it's just
corporate Democrat trash but I did
notice a certain something in the uh in
the piece do we have the uh the Tweet
there there was no one directly quoted
in the article it was people in quote
desantis's orbit it was people quote
close to the governor it was a guy
that's quote another person and as I
wrote and I tagged the two journalists
this isn't journalism it's fiction these
people are not journalists they're
creative writers that is not journalism
I'm sorry it's not journalism I get that
under certain circumstances perhaps with
State secrets
high-level FBI CIA stuff and I'm not
even sure I even agree with this there
could be some level at this point for
anonymous sources but it pretty much
doesn't work anymore knowing that the
media lies about everything you cannot
well you can do it I suppose Politico
can do it they put up an article and
then everything in it cannot be fact
checked because it was all people that
are in the orbit the orbit of DeSantis
what does that mean well I guess the
governor's mansion's up in Tallahassee
they got a Starbucks in Tallahassee I'm
guessing there's a Starbucks the
Starbucks is kind of in the orbit of the
governor's mansion and I spoke to the
guy who cleans the bathroom at the
Starbucks in Tallahassee orbit you see
what I'm doing there so these people lie
about everything and I only bring all of
this up
to push a theme that I'm always trying
to get across to you guys which is know
the way they lie know the way they lie
they want to create a fight and they
will lie and print articles and opinion
pieces and everything else with
Anonymous sources and people in orbit
and another guy said this and all of
that stuff so that they can get their
agenda across now I can get to the theme
of today's show which is that the agenda
ain't working and you guys are seeing
through it and it's not just you guys
it's it's almost everyone seeing through
it at this point and obviously the big
story of yesterday is that Elon Musk of
Tesla of SpaceX of neuralink of snarlink
he has officially bought Twitter for
better or worse and this is a major
threat to the establishment this is a
major threat to the corporations this is
a major threat to all of the people who
purport to be journalists lists but only
spread nonsense because what's going to
happen is there's going to now be I
assume this is what Elon is going to do
it's what he's been teasing along
there's going to be an even playing
field as opposed to Shadow Banning as
opposed to censoring as opposed to say
getting rid of accounts like project
Veritas when they do journalism exposing
people at Twitter perhaps putting the
former president of the United States
back on there so things are going to
start getting really interesting as if
they weren't getting interesting enough
knowing that we're about to roll into
these midterms so the point is guys we
have momentum we're close like we're
really close and
what does that Promised Land look like
that Promised Land just looks like
getting rid of these woke buffoons and
the sensorious people that are allies
with them and then just getting back to
America that we had 10 years ago then we
can we can do some other things around
that but that's really what I think we
can get back to I think we're really
really close but we got to know that we
can get there so that's what we're doing
today let me talk to you guys about
Patriot mobile real quick you know I
recently did a show on whoa corporations
and their Origins thankfully
conservatives are creating a parallel
economy that's thriving and I want to
tell you about a new sponsor that's
making a real difference Patriot mobile
has exploded over the last year they're
proud conservatives offering a real
alternative for people tired of funding
major cell phone carriers who've all
gone left Patriot mobile is a force for
conservative values this is because they
take a portion of your bill and fund
conservative causes and candidates
people who believe in the sanctity of
Life freedom of speech the Second
Amendment and they're winning in fact
their pack Patriot mobile action flipped
11 School Board races across Texas Texas
not too long ago Patriot mobile has
affordable plans for you your family
even your business they offer the same
Nationwide Nationwide coverage as the
major carriers because they use multiple
major networks so you get the same great
service minus the leftist propaganda go
to patriotmobile.com Reuben or call 972
Patriot get free activation when you use
the offer code Reuben special discounts
also available for veterans and First
Responders make the switch today in a
different tomorrow Patriot mobile.com
reubenpatriomobile.com Ruben or call 972
Patriot and now back to me all right so
it has happened we've been talking about
it for quite some time it looked like it
was going to happen then it wasn't going
to happen the board tried to stop it
from happening then he won it out then
the board wanted him in then the price
wasn't right then there were Bots it was
a whole thing I'm doing a lot with my
head right now you see what's happening
here but it has happened Elon Musk
officially has the Twitter and he walked
in to Twitter offices in sort of Elon
Musk fashion yesterday
[Laughter]
he's holding a sink that's right because
he wanted to let people have it sink in
that he was taking over you see what he
did there that is what he did uh and
then he got there and uh as far as I
know nobody jumped out of a window or
anything like that and then Elon even
tweeted this
meeting a lot of cool people people at
Twitter today okay so that that seems
pretty good let's give you a little more
context for what's going on here here's
some info from the daily wire
billionaire Elon Musk will reportedly
gut Twitter with massive cuts when he
takes over getting rid of the
overwhelming majority of the company The
Washington Post reported that musk told
prospective investors that he plans to
get rid of nearly 75 percent of
Twitter's 7500 workers whittling the
company down just to a skeleton staff of
over 2 000. the report said that the
plan cuts by Twitter's Executives helped
to explain why the company wanted to
sell to musk once he made the offer the
social media platform has been fighting
musk in court over his attempt to cancel
a previous offer to buy the company for
44 billion a move he said was driven by
concerns that Executives were
underestimating the actual number of
fake accounts on the platform musk
revived his efforts to purchase Twitter
earlier this month Beyond his concerns
about the fake accounts musk has voiced
criticism over lackluster's support on
Twitter for free expression he began his
shake-up campaign several months ago
with a poll for his millions of
followers regarding the platform's
adherence to the principle of free
speech okay so couple things here now
first off he's buying this at a premium
on the shares so the the if you own
shares of Twitter you're feeling really
good right now because who else was
going to buy this thing how legit is the
company is it all Bots are you even
really seeing ads on Twitter like it
just doesn't even feel like a functional
company it's a thing we all talk about
it's a thing that is transmitting
information it's basically the the pr
wire of the Modern Age it's it's so it's
obviously very relevant as annoying as
it might be and I would welcome all of
you that are not on there to stay not on
there but it it is an important thing
but what's interesting about this is uh
the two parts here so one well I guess
three parts he buys it for a crazy
amount of money
but now uh he also says hey I'm firing
75 of the people that's that's a pretty
rare thing that you would buy something
that you think is valuable and then also
come in and get rid of most of the
people however he knows most of the
people are woke activists they've been
the people doing the censoring uh we're
going to show you in a video in just a
moment it doesn't look like most of
these people actually work for a living
Etc et cetera so you're going to fire
most of the people but what's even more
interesting than that number three here
is that
this bot situation doesn't seem to have
been resolved yet no one seems to really
know perhaps Elon does perhaps this will
come out now in the next couple days I
would imagine that he and his guys right
now are just combing through documents I
don't know if it's on I don't know if
they print things over there on Twitter
or they're just doing it all on the
computer machine but they've got to be
combing through everything really trying
to figure out what did the programmers
do here to either inflate Bots or or
suppress certain information or Shadow
ban things or were workers checking
people's DMs I can only imagine what
they these people were doing and it's as
I always say when it comes to Big Tech
it's not the things that I can imagine
that they're doing it's the things that
I can't imagine that they're doing uh so
if you want to see a bit of what it's
like to work at Twitter this is so
incredible it's this is wild guys and
just trust me you two people in this
room right now you're never going to get
away with any of this stuff over there
uh This Is A Day in the Life a Twitter
employee actually posted this why would
he fire all these people what is it that
they're doing all day oh well Twitter
employee actually posted this not too
long ago
welcome to a day in my life as a Twitter
employee so this past week went to SF
for the first time at a Twitter office
badged in honestly took a moment to just
soak everything in what a blessing also
started my morning off with an iced
matcha from the perch then I had a
meeting so it's quickly scheduled one of
these little pod rooms which were so
cool they're literally noise canceling
took my meeting got ready for a bunch
look how delicious this food looks oh my
goodness I was so overwhelmed then made
my way down to this Log Cabin area I
don't know what this is but it was
really cool played some please developed
my friends to kind of unwind a bit
um also found this really cool
meditation room that I thought was super
neat
um I didn't do any yoga but they have
this yoga room if you are a yogi so I
also thought that was really cool
um had a couple more meetings in the
afternoon had a ton of projects that we
needed to knock out say hi to my
teammates
um went to the went to the library to
kind of get some more work done
obviously had to have our afternoon
coffee so made some espresso and then
before leaving for the day I had some
red wine
um that's on tap went up to the rooftop
and just honestly enjoyed the beautiful
weather so awesome trip I can't imagine
why he would be firing two-thirds of
these people I mean clearly they're not
doing work they're playing foosball uh
they're you know look it is true that
here at the Reuben report headquarters I
do have tequila on tap but that's for me
it's for me it's not for you guys you
guys can't just go to the tequila on tap
that we have here I mean how like that
is child it's such a it's childish
nonsense it's such an example of what
has happened with this generation that
we allowed to become part of these
companies and they destroy these
companies because they never became
mature because they never became adults
and they need to play foosball in the
middle of the day and drink wine and oh
it's just yes you're getting fired by
the way a bunch of people that work at
Twitter have been publicly going after
Elon since he has taken over and I'm
pretty sure that's grounds for dismissal
guys I just want to be very clear about
that if you ever tweet anything negative
about me you gotta pack it up no more
Chipotle play no more tequila no more
nothing uh I saw this funny meme of the
whole situation that kind of
encapsulates it so of course this is uh
from The Avengers Thanos and you know
when he snapped he was able to get rid
of all of the screaming Twitter people
that are there and yes so look the guy's
got a lot of power right now he has
absolutely a lot of power and what
happens when you have a lot of power
what happens when you're relevant or
interesting the machine starts moving on
you right what happened to say uh Joe
Rogan as he got bigger and bigger and
bigger and started questioning things
about Kobe the machine started saying he
was a racist and tried to get him booted
from Spotify and everywhere else this is
what happens so you can feel it and Elon
had to know this but it's kind of coming
for him now we've got more from the
daily wire on just that
President Joe Biden's Administration is
reportedly weighing subjecting Elon
musk's business dealings to National
Security reviews due to how much power
he is acquiring Bloomberg News reported
that the administration is specifically
wanting to scrutinize musk's Twitter
deal and spacex's starlink satellite
Network the news comes after The
Washington Post reported Thursday
afternoon that musk told prospective
investors that he plans to get rid of
nearly 75 percent of Twitter 75 7 500
workers whittling the company down to a
skeleton staff of just over 2 000. so
you can see what's happening here he's
he's coming out he's influencing things
the guy's got money he's invented an
awful lot of stuff right like I don't
begrudge many of his money I don't
begrudge him any of his power now he's
buying Twitter and the interesting one
about Twitter it's like this doesn't
strike me as like this is me going for
more money this this is an influence but
you are allowed to do that in a free
Society now the government's going to
look into him because they don't like
what he might do with Twitter now that's
bizarre because has the government been
looking into Twitter while Twitter was
censoring Hunter Biden has the
government been looking into Twitter
when Twitter uh blew up the account of
the sitting president of the United
States Donald Trump uh has Twitter has
the government looked into Twitter as
people from MSNBC and blue check people
and even the president of the United
States himself Joe Biden lied about the
covid vaccine and everything else but
now somebody that doesn't fully fit the
corporate narrative he's got the Twitter
he's got the blue check and this is a
problem for them uh and it's a problem
for us I think as well and here's
something that Elon tweeted that I think
also gets to the heart of it he said and
this is just yesterday he said a
beautiful thing about Twitter is how it
empowers citizen journalism people are
able to disseminate news without an
establishment bias yeah that's true and
that's what has made Twitter so great
for so many years that's why so many
people have been angry at Twitter
because when
alternative voices
me Shapiro Crowder the Lefty versions of
us whatever it is just people that are
outside of the mainstream thing outside
of the corporate thing when we started
to get momentum when we started to
expose the nonsense uh then they started
censoring us so the the whole thing kind
of flipped on itself Twitter became it
was originally supposed to be this open
platform and if you if you were doing
something good and you're doing
something funny perhaps and irreverent
and interesting you're going to get more
traction get more tweets but then it got
taken over by Bots and fake numbers you
know the New York Times has how many how
many Twitter followers does the New York
Times have something like I'm gonna
guess it's something like 60 million
they get four retweets I could literally
you know post a picture of my ChapStick
and a glass of water and get more than
that and I'm Shadow banned to high hell
you get it but but why is it why is it
that we should even care why should you
watching this care about Twitter and why
should you care whether the
establishment uh has anything to push
back or not well the thing is that the
establishment runs cover for one side
and tries to destroy another the New
York Times by the way has 55 million uh
55 million Twitter followers so I want
to show you in a perfect example of how
the corporate press runs cover for one
side and tries to destroy the other side
as I just said so here's a tweet from
The New York Times uh this is in
reference to what's going on in
Pennsylvania and John fetterman who we
talked about who's having all sorts of
cognitive problems having trouble
speaking unable to clearly lay out what
his ideas are etc etc so here's what
they wrote about him doctors and
Disability Rights Advocates said John
fetterman's debate appearance was
inspiring for many disabled people and
that his halting speech didn't reflect
any cognitive impairment I don't know
how you could know that as a doctor just
by watching somebody but okay even so
some Democrats are worried voters may
seem may see it differently so what's
interesting about that is you can see
the running cover for him running cover
and using the words of doctors who have
not looked at him to you know protect
him from the things that we can all see
this is a little bit different than say
a headline that they had against
Republican Herschel Walker not too long
ago Walker says he has overcome Mental
Illness but it's not so simple experts
say the New York Times so when one guy
who's on their side a Democrat can't
speak well it's not really that new to
do when the other guy who's the
Republican has overcome mental illness
well known to witness not say he's
overcome it there's some other problems
you guys get it it's just important to
expose this nonsense it's deeply
important to expose it and why is it
important to expose it because the left
has gone crazily radical they at this
point with almost no exceptions and when
I always say this it's always I don't
mean your aunt who was a 60s liberal who
doesn't know what time it is now the
entire left Democrat machine has gone
crazy radical how crazy radical has it
gotten well Raphael Warnock who is a
senator from Georgia he's the guy that
is the incumbent that uh that Herschel
Walker wants to displace uh here he is
he's a preacher as well here he is in
his church preaching and and you tell me
does this sound uh does this sound Godly
does this sound uh what one might go to
church for or does it sound
um racist I don't no matter what happens
next month more than a third of the
nation that would go along with this is
reason to be afraid
America needs to repent for its worship
of whiteness
on full display
no America does not need to repent for
its worship of whiteness first off
America does not worship whiteness
secondly you Raphael Warnock and the
people that follow you you are the
racists because you believe that all
white people must think the same thing
while at the same time believing that
all black people must think the same
thing right because you're not really
thrilled with black people who think
differently Herschel Walker right
um this this constant drive it's almost
done guys it's almost done if these
elections go the way that they should
we're almost past it and it's not that
it's going to stop it'll always be there
it'll always morph they'll always try to
get your kids it'll just keep going like
it it won't stop and be banned into
Oblivion but we can do something major
in 10 days and the fact that that clip
is not on every mainstream media uh
Outlet right now that thing should be
going it's going viral within the
conservative Circles of course here's
Rafael Warnock making up something about
the United States in essence calling
half of the country if not more racist
and all of that stuff this endless
assault on white people which
interestingly remember when what was it
about two weeks ago when Tulsi gabbard
former Democrat former Democrat
candidate for the presidency remember
when she gave her little speech as to
why she was leaving the party she said
it also had something to do with how
anti-white the party had become yeah
it's right in our freaking faces but
what else is it it's not just that they
are the racists it's also what I said
earlier that they run cover for these
people so the average person who doesn't
have all data analyze politics
and think things through the average
person is just flipping television
flipping on television flipping the
channels and they stop on certain things
and they go oh my God Republicans must
be horrible and Democrats must be so
nice because that's the way everything's
framed here is noted racist Sunny Hosten
on The View
and I think it takes real courage to
show that you've been knocked down I
think it takes real bravery to allow
people to see your weakness right and
um we know that fetterman's cognitive
abilities have not been compromised it's
about expression right that has been
compromised Aphasia exactly and you know
this is a smart guy okay so first off
how do we know that his cognitive
abilities have not been compromised I
know they keep saying it right and
doctors who have not uh examined him say
it to the New York Times and she says it
there but how do we know now again I
have total sympathy with him as a stroke
victim and anyone that is dealing with
any cognitive stuff and having trouble
speaking or any of the things so I am
not making a joke about that at all I'm
showing you the way they run cover
imagine if Ted Cruz suddenly was having
trouble speaking imagine if Rand Paul
was slurring his words and really
confused and seemingly didn't know where
he years they would be going off on it
they would be absolutely going off and
and not only they'd be going off on it
and making fun of them they'd also be
saying and you see it proves that
they're that their constituents are
morons and racists and everything else
because no matter whether the guy can
speak or not they're still going to
support them so everything they do is a
lie everything they do is a lie and oh
my Lord I have a perfect segue speaking
of liars because the other debate that
was uh two nights ago yesterday
obviously we covered the fetterman Oz
debate
uh and uh the other debate was this
Gretchen Whitmer she is the governor of
Michigan uh and she is going against
Republican Tudor Dixon and if you want
to just see a liar in action like an
incredible extraordinary liar and they
only do it because they can get away
with it here's Gretchen Whitmer Governor
you've been in office for four years now
Harry Truman said the buck stops at your
desk you've had four years to try to fix
education in this state why is it not
where you would want it to go at least
four years ago where you said you wanted
to go we've also had some historic
challenges over the last few years I
think to put it lately you know Mrs
Dixon says that I kept students out
longer than any other state that's just
not true I worked closely with my
Republican and Democratic governor so
kids were out for three months why lie
you liar and we all know it Michigan had
some of the most Draconian lockdowns
there are a million articles house kids
were out for well more than that how
when schools wanted to reopen she worked
with the the teachers unions to keep the
kids out she also this is the same woman
that literally did not want people
gardening she she banned the sale of
plants and vegetables that we we saw
plenty of images of it I actually sent I
went shopping in Crazy dystopian Los
Angeles I went to my Home Depot and I
bought a bunch of seeds and I sent them
to fans in Michigan she is a liar and a
terrible human being
but fortunately there was another person
on that stage Republican Tudor Dixon and
she was not having it I'm pretty sure I
just heard an audible gasp around town
when Gretchen Whitmer said that kids
were out of school for three months
perhaps she wasn't paying attention to
what was actually happening even we even
had schools that were closed this year
this is shocking to me that she thinks
that schools were only closed for three
months or maybe she thinks she can
convince you that schools were only
closed for three months but you know
better because your students are the
ones that are desperately behind and the
test scores show that she's being
dishonest about this she's being
dishonest about even trying to get into
these schools to get these schools back
on track yeah that's good that's clear
that's honest that's great it's exactly
what I always say you tell the truth you
say it clearly but the thing is Whitmer
knows she can say outright lies like
that because of again media running
cover for Democrats so she has the balls
to get up there the the moderator should
have been like what the f are you
talking about lady this past year not
2020. this past year we were still
closing down some schools here
okay so be it uh Tudor Dixon who I did
not know a tremendous amount about
before this debate uh she went after the
debate she got all the media around her
like there were like 20 reporters right
in her face and she just plowed through
question after question after question
after question and did an absolutely
great job the the Democrats obviously
are never subjected to that sort of uh
situation uh here's about 30 seconds of
it can you maybe talk about that you
know what would have to go wrong I guess
for you not to accept results made it
clear that she runs an illegal election
again that would be a problem I'm hoping
that she won't do that
tutor you Jonathan Osteen Bridge
Michigan um you claim the governor
forced people to get vaccines can you
clarify that comment Michigan never had
amended um I was talking about her vax
to normal program that said if we wanted
to have our freedoms and Liberties back
then we had to get to a certain
percentage of people that were vaxed
tutor Zach Workshop from Dogwood service
you've been critical of
fools remaining closed but as Governor
what would you have done for school
districts their school boards decided we
are going to remain in a virtual pasture
instead of going to in person what could
you have not what would you have done we
saw other states like Florida that said
we are going to have schools in person
that that's critical and that's what we
should have done in the state of
Michigan we saw schools that we saw
other states opening their schools and
the children were safe and they ended up
having much less learning loss than the
state of Michigan this is Dixon Samantha
Rich from the Michigan Daily um Governor
Whitmer kind of stressed her record of
bipartisan collaboration and I'm just
wondering what your plan is to work
across the aisle yeah it's interesting
that she is talks about that because
there are actually legislators that
she's never met so I would sit down with
our legislators and meet with them
regularly all right that's a small
portion of it she just went on and on
and on tried a picture can you even
picture a Democrat getting that kind of
scrutiny just question question question
what Democrat operative that would work
for a campaign would even allow even if
it was even if it could possibly happen
What Democrat operative would allow
their candidate to be subjected to
questions like that they never would but
there she just stood there you go you go
you go you go she didn't lie she didn't
obfuscate anything else so the real
danger here is that if someone like
Gretchen Whitmer gets elected again what
is the signal that will be sent to her
it will be oh hot damn I can lock people
out I can force vaccines I can crush the
economy and these clowns which is I
guess all you can call them at this
point these clowns will say thank you
sir may I have another can you govern Me
Harder could you do that for me that
would be just great could you take more
of my money and more of my autonomy you
somehow Gretchen Whitmer are better than
me and know how to live my life so the
point is they CA that's why this
election is so important it's cliche to
say that sort of thing this election is
the most important but this is it people
because they will bring all of the crap
back don't believe me well Anthony
fauci's back here he is yesterday and
yeah yeah he still wants you to get
injected with his experimental stuff the
updated the bivalent covid boosters that
they work about as well as the original
boosters but no better which had of
course been hoped that they would be
kind of they would be more protective if
you will when the researchers compared
the immune responses of people who got a
booster dose of the original shot to the
people who got the updated bivalent
coveted booster shots
um they they looked the way that the
research shows is they looked about the
same is that disappointing news
right
well if if that is the case it's not
that disappointing because both of them
work very well I might comment that
those studies they came from very good
institutions and very good investigators
both of whom I know well
but they're still not peer-reviewed and
the numbers in those studies were small
right what I'm really looking forward to
Kate is the full data that we'll be
getting hopefully within the next couple
of weeks at the latest from the FDA who
will get the totality of the data that
was submitted to them by the companies
that did the study so I think the jury
is still out about that but even if it
turns out they're equivalent they both
did very well which means there's no
reason not to and a very good reason to
get your updated booster shot all right
that's absolutely right it had me
thinking about just how you have to
especially with the influenza vaccine
how you have to plan ahead
that's absolutely right that's
absolutely right oh my God I'm such a
journalist that's absolutely right um
sure the last booster didn't really work
and we all kind of know it which is why
everybody has 87 boosters and the head
of the CDC wolensky she has covet right
now besides 17 boosters and 87 other
shots and everything else oh you're just
you're just so good you're such a good
man who's watching this anyway the point
is the first booster it just really
didn't work and we all know it and we
know that the vaccines don't stop
transmission and all of that stuff and
now they're saying the new booster isn't
any better but he has to keep the grift
going he's he's so in on it and the guy
is worth five million more dollars than
he was worth two years ago he's gotta
keep the thing going and what will they
do if they retain power in about 10 days
uh what will they do well they will be
sure as hell to take that signal boy
these people want more of it and they
will figure out other ways to censor you
because they've been doing it all along
uh check this out this is from a guy by
the name at Jason Leopold and he had
used a Freedom of Information Act to
request to get some info here he got an
email from Zuckerberg to fauci on March
15th we're building a coronavirus Hub I
think it would be useful to include a
video from you because people trust and
want to hear from experts rather than a
bunch of agencies and political leaders
this is March 15th of 2020 so this is at
the height of all of this now it's
interesting so here's fauci at that time
working for Donald Trump by the way and
they are asking Facebook is saying hey
can you work with us to spread
information now we know that basically
everything fauci has said for two years
was a lie but Facebook at that time
wanted to work with him to get
information out and uh do you think that
maybe the administration was also
working with Facebook directly uh yeah
remember this one this is from the New
York Post White House Press Secretary
Jen saki said Thursday this is about a
year and a half ago that the Biden
Administration is identifying
problematic posts for Facebook to censor
because they contain misinformation
about covid-19 saki disclosed the
government's role in policing social
media during her Daily Press briefing
after Surgeon General vivec Murphy
Murphy called on companies to purge more
pandemic posts the demand for censorship
and saki's admission of the government
involvement follows a series of
flip-flops from Health officials who
contradicted themselves throughout the
pandemic on issues such as ask efficacy
as well as censorship of claims that
later gained creative credibility such
as the theory that covid-19 leaked from
a Chinese lab we are in regular touch
with the social media platforms and
those engagements typically happen
through members of our senior staff and
also members of our covid-19 team given
as Dr Murthy conveyed this is a big
issue of misinformation specifically on
the pandemic saki said I honestly
believe guys honestly that could have
and perhaps should have taken the entire
Administration down right there the
First Amendment says that the government
cannot infringe on your speech if the
government compels a private company
or a public company to infringe on your
speech then that is as close to directly
the government doing it as possible yes
they did not send Jack booted thugs into
someone's house to force them to delete
the post on Facebook but they said to
the company do our dirty work for us and
do you think that maybe that comes with
a little threat we're going to maybe
break you up or we're going to somehow
regulate you or something else and of
course all of the people that they were
saying were sharing misinformation like
Dr Robert Malone who has since been
booted off uh off Twitter the guy who
has I think more mRNA vaccine technology
patents than anybody they turned out to
be right about almost everything there
was this other guy and I he's a bit of a
right-wing up nut job so you're gonna
have to bear with me on this one some
guy named Dave Rubin he's got some he's
always babbling about God knows what for
a living remember when he tweeted this
back in July of 2021 they want a federal
vaccine mandate for vaccines which are
clearly not working as promised just
just weeks ago people are getting and
transmitting covid despite vacs plus now
they're prepping us for booster shots a
sane society would take a pause we do
not live in a sane society that nut job
Dave Rubin was suspended on Twitter for
that of course everything that he said
and again the guy is completely bananas
and should not be listened to turns out
everything he said there was uh totally
true totally 100 true and interestingly
the way he worded it uh by saying at the
end we should just take pause and talk
about it uh seems like a pretty measured
way of saying it especially for right
wing Maniac but here we are let's shift
all together because I couldn't even
exactly figure out the way to get the
Segway from that to this but I saw this
video yesterday it's so insane well I
think I can figure out a segue a Segway
would be something like these people are
bananas they are nuts and crazy and
everything they say is is psychotic
whether it's covid whether it's race
whether it's chopping genitals children
genital children's genitals off or the
rest of it
um so I guess really though what it
would come down to here's the segue for
you would you really want this guy to be
in charge of your spirit speech here's
Joe Biden yesterday basically saying
that black people don't know how to buy
airline tickets
some Airlines if you want six more
inches between you and the seat in front
you pay more money
but you don't know it until you purchase
your ticket
look folks these are junk fees they're
unfair in the marginalized Americans the
hardest especially low-income folks and
people of color
they Benefit Big corporations not look
Joe Biden's racist the Democrats that
support this nonsense they are racist he
literally just said that black people
don't understand that if you buy a seat
in premium class where you get in a
couple inches left these things somehow
affect black people more they have no
idea what they're doing he also said you
don't know it until you buy the ticket
well no [ __ ] you go on the website I
often fly on JetBlue I like JetBlue okay
they let you they have their little
thing there where you're allowed to get
chips yourself you know so you're a real
adult you could just walk up and get
chips it's very exciting uh they have
something called even more space so when
you're selecting your seat if you select
an even more space seat which gives you
you're not going to believe this even
more space uh you're gonna get charged a
little more money this is something in
capitalism where if you get a better
service or you get more of a product you
often have to pay more money for it this
is the free exchange of goods Joe Biden
seems to think black people cannot do
this they don't understand this Joe
Biden also thinks black people don't
know where to get IDs now this is very
odd because you need an ID to get on a
plane so you would think these black
people who don't know how to get on a
plane in the first place why would they
even care about the six more inches of
space
God help us
God help us what are they talking about
what are they doing to all of us why are
they doing it
we got to put these people out to
pasture we really do I mean
I'm gonna call my black friend and ask
if he has been able to so stupid so
stupid
anyway so what do we have to do when it
comes to all this their stupid ideas
you're going to keep coming they're
going to keep Banning us they're going
to keep deleting us and everything else
well what do we have to do we have to
get brave people to step up and now to
bring us full circle here that's what
Elon Musk is doing here right Twitter is
not going to be some great financial win
for him it just isn't the business model
doesn't make sense but he's paying an
awful lot of money for it because I I
believe that he believes in free speech
and I think that that will help us
correct all of this stuff because
sunlight is the best disinfectant so you
may remember this video this is I think
about two months ago when he first
started saying that maybe he was going
to buy it and he was at least looking
into it why did he even care well he
laid it out
I I do think that we want to be just
very reluctant to delete things and and
have um just just be very cautious with
with with permanent bands uh you know
timeouts I think are better or uh than
than sort of permanent bands and um
uh but just just in general like I said
uh how how it won't be perfect but I
think we wanted to really uh have like I
said Obsession and reality that speeches
as free as reasonably possible
it's really again it's like when people
are telling the truth you just know
they're telling the truth what does it
say it won't be perfect I don't think he
loves the idea of the little timeouts
but he also doesn't want people going on
Twitter and threatening other people
which of course if you do that on
Twitter you do that on any other
platform you have a bigger problem than
big Tech you have a legal problem right
but what he's saying is we want reality
and perception to to add up so we can
all make some sense of the world that's
why it's so it's so Twisted what
happened with Twitter Twitter when for
when it first came out it was this
incredible reflection of all of us like
you could put something out there and
then people would see it and it was
unmanipulated and the feed was
chronological and you could put
something out and if you said something
funny or smart or interesting people
would share it and they'd communicate
with you and then it and then it got
weird so at first it was a mirror it was
just a mirror for society hey here's
what I'm putting out there it's
reflecting back on me there's something
to to make sense of here but then over
time because of Shadow bands because of
deletions and censorship it became a fun
house mirror and what happens when you
look at a fun house mirror well then the
place that we used to look at the mirror
and reflect to get an honest reflection
you go my hair's a little this today it
became a fun house mirror and everything
was distorted and perhaps do you think
when the biggest thing related the
biggest platform related to PR how
public relations travel how the culture
wore his foot when that thing
instead of being a mirror becomes a
distorting product do you think that
might lead us to where we are right now
so maybe between these elections between
him getting this thing right now maybe
there's a chance maybe the thing is
turning but you know what even if he
gets this thing and fix it we still need
alternative platforms no matter what
which of course is why I started locals
it's why we merged with Rumble and just
a quick thing on the rumble front
because rumble's doing a lot of good
stuff right now I think we have a tweet
from Rumble update in less than 24 hours
Steve will do it so you guys know Steve
he's from the milk boys and he's gone
huge on Rumble right now he's got more
than 700 000 total views and 300 000
unique views on his first video his
channel is already at 175 000
subscribers and the only reason I'm even
mentioning that is because his first
video he went down to Fort Myers Florida
he gave away a whole bunch of trailers
and products and goods and services to
people donating a ton of money and it's
like guys there are people that are
doing good things out there and guess
what Steve yeah banned from YouTube
that's why he's doing that on Rumble
right now uh so what does this all lead
us to I was trying to think well how do
we wrap this show up in a nice tight bow
what what are we really saying here well
if we can clean up the communication if
we can get rid of the politicians who
lie like Whitmer and the bureaucrats who
who want power over you that they don't
deserve like fauci what can we get back
to well we could get back to a state
that is
slim and trim and respectful of our
rights because it didn't give us our
rights it is there to defend those
rights this is a beautiful throwback
video we got for you a former prime
minister of Britain Margaret Thatcher on
why the state
is not necessarily your friend when it
comes to Freedom
the essence of socialism is that you
surrender quite a bit of power over your
own life to the state where we all do
that to some extent but of course it
went much further
you pay very high taxes and they wish to
um take even higher taxes because they
think that politicians can spend money
better than the people can spend it the
more you take away the less there is for
Private Industry and that's where the
creation of wealth comes so you have to
establish very clear limits on the role
of government and really you'll know
politicians I think should sometimes
just be a little bit more modest about
their abilities than they are we can't
run everything and we shouldn't
is the bachelor though you're going for
attitudes you know when the state does
everything for you it'll soon take
everything from you
you will then have no basis for personal
freedom
political freedom
nor economic freedom I saw it going much
too far and I think it would have gone
even further had I not won that 1979
election too far ever to pull it back
do I have to even add much to that is
that not the heart of everything that I
talk about here
imagine if the state was just slim and
trim and it couldn't give everything to
you and it couldn't take everything away
it had no power to lock you in your
house or force you to be ejected with
something sure it made sure there were
police they made sure we had a border
a couple other little things
but then it stayed out of your way and
you had more money in your pocket to do
with your resources what you see fit
and you could speak freely and all of
that stuff that's how this is all set up
to be and we have been getting very
close to that Cliff where we would give
it all away and this is a cyclical thing
in time that's what she's talking about
there because she had an election where
she felt hey we're getting close to
socialism we're getting close to giving
it away that's where we're at we're
close we're close and if the election
does not go the way that I think it will
go the signal will have been sent to all
of the people that want more control
over your lives Gavin Newsom will get
the signal and he'll go I'll keep going
Gretchen Whitmer will get the signal
she'll go I'll keep going then Trudeau
will look at the election and go ah see
look at those Americans I'm going to
keep going and they will keep going and
going and going Kathy hochel will keep
going so what's happening a couple brave
people are stepping up Tudor Dixon is
stepping up in Michigan Lee zeldon is
stepping up in New York Elon Musk is
stepping up on the tech side right more
and more people are stepping up and
eventually there are more of us than
there are of them and our ideas are
right so that's what you should be armed
with when you go forward it's like we've
the right ideas
and there's more of us and maybe we just
needed to be a little bit braver that's
where we at that's exactly where we're
at at the moment somebody did a video on
prageru called The Bravery deficit who
was that guy it was the same guy that
got booted off the Twitter for that
other tweet that I read before we're odd
a couple comments from the
reubenreport.locals.com community Tony
says Reuben report employees have
Chick-fil-A sauce and guacamole on tap
actually you know what we're getting for
lunch today did Daphne tell you
we're getting the Chipotle today and I
did get extra guacamole yeah we haven't
had it in a while there's been a lot of
salads around here I'm just trying to
you know stay fit but yes we are getting
uh Chipotle today and yes that's funny
we have Chipotle oh no what's the
Chick-fil-A it's just Chick-fil-A sauce
right it's just called Chick-fil-A sauce
we've got that on tap downstairs uh Jeff
says good morning from a soon to be
ex-california and congratulations man
there are so many people in the
community almost every day in the
community I see people posting I'm
getting out of here here's my U-Haul I'm
fleeing this place blah blah blah blah
blah that's fantastic good for you Ann
says I can't imagine musk keeping
Twitter headquarters in San Francisco
yeah that seems hard to believe they
still are in San Francisco look he moved
uh out of California himself obviously
for tax purposes but he moved Tesla to
Texas uh he's moving an awful lot of his
stuff out of the state he's also selling
a lot of his properties and everything
else I mean Elon if you're watching this
Florida would be pretty freaking
fantastic I just moved two companies
here right locals is right here in Miami
the production company is right here our
production company is right here in
Miami plus Rumble is in Sarasota there
is there's infrastructure here you have
a friendly government that doesn't want
your taxes and wants to create
opportunity you can get non-social
Justice Warriors to work for you
um he has a real Challenge on his hands
but hopefully he's up for it and
hopefully you know the proof will be in
the pudding we'll see over the course of
the next week or two does Twitter start
feeling like it's not being as
censorious are the shadow bands going to
be lifted do the follower accounts make
sense and then what will happen if we
have that even playing field what like I
think that is actually something for us
all to think about before I sign off
today like if we got that even playing
field back right
the which was the promise of the
internet that we're all just going to
put our stuff out there and see what
happens if we got that playing field
back how would we all react to it
because the the obvious truth is that
the lefties who have been in control for
so long and have been using the levers
of censorship uh they're going to be
very upset by what will happen when we
have that even playing field and for
those of us that have been on the other
side of that the the censored side of it
it's like are we going to feel more
emboldened and maybe that helps flip the
script as well I'm very hopeful today on
this fine Wednesday no to Thursday it's
Thursday what man time is flying by
it's crazy crazy crazy crazy uh guys
don't forget to like And subscribe on
YouTube Rumble and anywhere else if you
want to play along during the live chat
and get our videos early and add free
and go to Ruben report.locals.com
and uh we leave you with a cold close as
I often say you don't have to be a
republican but you cannot be a Democrat
never forget
Democrat lockdowns never forget
Democrats defund the police Mercedes
burn gas expensive as hell inflation out
of control never forget Democrats did
this to you do different vote they are
the cheap gas and affordable groceries
vote for people who will leave you alone
vote they are for safety security
Insanity both the arm vote Republican
thank you